senator harry reid thank you so much for
joining me on the show
amy coney barrett took her seat on the
supreme court this week barely a week
out from the election
how badly do you think your former
colleagues the senate democrats
handled their opposition to her hearings
given they
ended with more americans backing her
confirmation
before the election than when they
started
well i think that
the proof's in the pudding we're going
to have to see what she's going to do
on the court and until then we'll just
have to hope that she
follows precedent and doesn't try to
legislate from the bench
but in terms of their actual opposition
do you think they did the strongest job
possible
i think that republicans were bound and
determined to get her approved
as quickly as possible and they had the
ability to do that and that's what they
did
so the republicans say that the real
reason
all of this has happened the way it did
the real reason the senate is so
polarized today
that judicial confirmations are so
polarized is not anything they did
but they say it's what you did going
nuclear in 2013
and getting rid of the filibuster for
judicial nominations gop senator ben
sasse
name checked you on the senate floor on
monday saying you
not mitch mcconnell were the senator
most responsible for the confirmations
of amy coney barrett and brett kavanaugh
and neil gorsuch
even some democrats in the senate like
michael bennett
have said that that decision of yours
was a mistake it backfired
are they wrong absolutely totally 100
wrong let's go back to where we were
barack obama was president a very
popular president
and the republicans were filibustering
everything for the first time in the
history of this country
they filibustered the secretary of
defense who by the way was a republican
chuck hago from nebraska we had
vacancies on the dc circuit
second most important court in the
country and they would not allow us to
fill them
the national labor relations board they
couldn't directly attack
union membership which they hated union
members
so what they did they made it so we
couldn't get a quorum for the national
labor relations board
obama couldn't get his cabinet his sub
cabinet officers approved
so we had no choice and remember this is
not the first time in the history of the
country
the rules have been changed they've been
tearing numerous times
and looking back it was the right thing
to do
we got president obama who had one of
the most successful
congresses in the history of the country
more successful even than
the time that
roosevelt was president his first term
he was most successful congress in the
history of the country
so i think that and looking back
it's certainly we did the right thing
it was the best thing to do you know we
had
we were also faced with all those
filibusters
um 1113th congress
over 250 filibusters in prior years
there were basically none two or three
at the most
so we did the right thing it was good
for the country
it it gave us the affordable care act it
gave us the most successful
reform of wall street in the history of
the country with
the dodd-frank bill we did literally lit
better to put women on
more equal footing with pay than it had
been in the past
we did lots of good things that were
really important for the country
and there is no regret whatsoever that
we did that
the ability for donald trump to appoint
hundreds of new judges to the federal
judiciary
was also a fallout from that decision
too was it not no that's not true
remember we made it so it took a super
majority to get supreme court justice
approved they're the ones that changed
that democrats didn't do that
they didn't my point is that
the republicans are the ones that
changed the ruling regarding supreme
court justice
we didn't do that we had a super
majority they changed that
so do you believe talking of changing
rules do you believe that if democrats
take back the senate and white house
that they should do away with the
legislative filibuster as well because
last year
you said in the new york times that it
was quote suffocating the will of the
people
but then earlier this week you said
senate democrats
if they get a majority should quote give
the republicans a little bit of time
to see if they're going to work with
biden you said no more than three weeks
what could republicans possibly show us
in those three weeks
that they haven't already shown us all
these years
biden is a peacemaker he always tries to
get along
and i said to him i said this publicly
that give them a little bit of time to
see if they're going to play ball with
you i know they won't
but give them some time and i think we
should change the filibuster
it is it's time is gone its usefulness
is
not here anymore and that was recognized
in a speech given
at john lewis's funeral by barack obama
where he said it's part of jim crow
it needs to go and i have no doubt that
it's going to go it's just a question
not if but when it's going to go
you can't have a democratically elected
body to take 60
of the vote to get something passed
people don't understand that
and they're right and not understanding
because it's wrong
your former aide adam gentleson goes
even further
than you he came on this show on tuesday
and said that if democrats
regain a senate majority they should not
only kill the filibuster
but immediately move for statehood for
puerto rico and the district of columbia
do you agree with him and if not why not
well i think that maybe adam's going
going past the skis as they say i've
always
favored uh statehood for d.c
and puerto rico but we've got to just
kind of take it easy i think we need to
not rush in and try to throw our elbows
around and
see what we can do and to get along i
think
there's comes a time that we have to see
if we can develop some
bipartisanship in congress they should
be given
time to work with us as we should be
given time to work with them
but but senator after eight years of
obama and biden being blocked at every
turn not a single vote for the aca
the delegitimization of the first black
president's presidency by this party
four years of trump uh breaking norms
ramming through nominations three
supreme court justices
one six days out seven days out from an
election
can you really still talk about
bipartisanship isn't that just naive
senator
well i think that that we were able to
show
during obama's presidency that we could
get some things done
and one reason we got things done is we
changed the rules i did that
and the democrats supported me we proved
the fact that you can do that with a
simple majority and as we look forward i
think we should look forward to changing
whatever rules we need to change
we need to look at what should be done
if anything on the supreme court
i think biden's handling that well
saying that he thinks so what we need to
do
is appoint a independent body
to made up of citizens around the
country
and give them uh six months to come up
with some ideas as to what we should do
with the court there are many things
that we need to work on
and joe biden is a perfect person
because he is known
as being someone who tries to work out
things with people remember
compromise is not a nasty word
legislation is the art of compromise
anyone that doesn't understand that
never gets anything done in congress
but but senator that's just it's not
true though is it the republicans have
proved that you can get stuff done
without compromise they haven't
compromised
and yet they've got three supreme court
justices they've got tax
cuts done they've got multiplicity of
things done without compromising at all
oh i think that they haven't gotten what
they
everything they wanted done i think that
they've been
they've done they've been very narrow in
what they've tried to do
but i think their legacy here is not
that the tax cuts are something that um
they're on their way out everybody knows
that because
biden has said that anyone making less
than 400 000
a year are not going to have any tax
increase of people making more than 400
000
a year will have that so i i just think
that
we should look at that class being half
full rather than half empty i think we
can look forward to getting a lot done
okay we may have to change
some of the things we've done in the
past but it can get done because we're
going to have
a democratic president we're going to
have a stronger majority in the house
than we have right now and we're going
to have a democratic controlled senate
that's a positive prediction there from
you you also mentioned the supreme court
you now have senate democrats and
independents like
chris coons and angus king legendary
moderate
centrists people have always said like
you just said compromise isn't a dirty
word
and yet they're saying they're so fed up
of republican extremism on this
that they're now open to the idea of
expanding the supreme court
do you agree with them are you open to
it as well well you mentioned two of my
favorite senators
of all time uh the independent from
maine
he's such a he's i've always told him he
looks like a senator
and he acts like one and he is one and
chris coons of course is
somebody i've admired for before he
before he's elected height
uh was openly supporting him
he's a fine senator and very smart
but what's your view on supreme court
expansion do you agree with them that
you're open to it i i agree with biden i
think it's something that we should
have a independent a commission
appointed
report back in six months see if what
they come up with is something we should
do
but it isn't it isn't something we
should ignore the supreme court is not a
stable body
congress has a right with a simple
majority to change it any way they want
instead of having nine justices we could
have five we could afford
we could have 12. so we could do that
with a simple majority but
i think biden's right let's let's look
the look
outside congress come upside ideas and
see if we're going to follow what
the american people feel they need
but just to check and forgive me for
pushing you senator i understand joe
biden's reasons for
having a commission and waiting a few
months you're now a private citizen so
i'm going to ask you again what is your
own personal view
do you support expanding the core
i approve of making sure that we
do what we can to make sure we
understand what we're doing
and by that if we don't want to go with
the commission that is suggested by
biden
we least should have a select committee
of congress to look at it and make some
decisions as what
the alternatives are yes we should look
at if the court needs to stay the way it
is
i don't necessarily think that it should
i think we should
take a look at ways to change it but we
should just rush into it
um just on standing up to the gop
if you were senate majority leader come
january 2021
would you keep dianne feinstein on as
senate judiciary committee chair
given how she praised lindsey graham's
handling of those confirmation hearings
and even ended them by giving him a hug
is it time for someone different someone
tougher
chuck schumer will make those decisions
to make the right decision but as far as
i'm concerned
dianne feinstein is one of the most
dignified people that has ever served in
congress
and of course that's who she is she is
not
uh doing anything other than expressing
to
lindsey graham fact that she's she and
he
are the people who run that committee
and it was over with and it was hard
and there's no reason she shouldn't
reach out and shake his hand and give
him a hug
but what i'm trying to understand is the
democrats whole strategy was these
hearings are
illegitimate uh they're stealing a seat
they should wait for the election to
happen
uh lindsey graham is doing this for his
own you know personal parties and
motives
and at the end of it the senior democrat
on that committee says actually the
hearings were great and gives them a hug
even chuck schumer i believe uh gave her
a call to say he wasn't happy about that
well i think that it's a little
difficult to uh
criticize dianne feinstein with such a
stunning career
uh try to belittle her for
being nice that's who she is but she
didn't do anything wrong
hearing's over with she says to her
ranking member i was hired to this
chairman of the committee good
luck glad to work with you i i
i don't you belittle her at all for that
okay
you have changed your views about
certain republicans eight years ago
you say you were a fan of lindsey graham
and you were pretty tough critic of mitt
romney
today you're full of praise for romney
and viciously critical of graham
what changed well i over the years i've
not been consistent
i changed because the facts change
lindsey graham
used to be independent he was a rebel
with john mccain
with john mccain's passing he became a
sycophant
for donald trump goes golfing with him
and says all these nice things about him
i it's hard for me to say this but i
hope that
lindsay loses the race because he
certainly deserves to uh
i have lost such respect for him or how
he's become a lap dog for donald trump
and mitt romney and i are friends
um we've had some knock-down drag-out
battles
but we've met and talked about how we
treated each other and we both
acknowledged that we could have done a
little better
shook hands and i admired what he's done
he's been
one of the few people that stood up to
trump
so i'm guessing based on what you were
just saying about making up with romney
that you now regret
personally attacking romney in 2012 i
think you falsely at the time accused
he was then the gop presidential
candidate of not having paid taxes for
10 years
something you later said you think
helped cost in the election i'm assuming
you've come i don't really i don't
regret that for that
i don't regret that at all it was what i
did was right
uh there was indications that his taxes
should be looked at
and you know after it's all over with he
never gave us his tax returns all he
gave us is a summary of them
so that was uh what i did then is
nothing i regret it was something that
was done
in that edith battle and i have no
regret for what i did i think i did the
right thing for the country
well now you're both friends maybe you
can dig into whether he paid taxes or
not as you claimed at the time people
say that was a false claim
one last question senator rita we
appreciate your time i have to ask
nevada of course is home to area 51 and
a host of other
secretive federal military and nuclear
sites and you've been in the news in
recent years for being privy to some of
the most
sensitive information the u.s has about
alleged
ufos i'm laughing here but a serious
question you're smiling are we alone in
the universe
or do you are you about the information
that suggests that we have been visited
what about that little green man on your
shoulder this morning
uh i mean seriously you you have all
this secret information can you tell us
anything about what we know about
life beyond something that it's
something that i was
have been interested in i talked to
senator in a way from hawaii
senator stevens from alaska they though
those that handled the dark money of the
defense budget and i said
you know with all these instances of
uh unidentified flying objects
why don't we take a look at this and
they agreed in fact senator stephen said
i was in world war
ii he was a fighter pilot airplanes he's
up in the airplane
see something off his wing tried to go
sideways up down he couldn't get rid of
it
got low on fuel he went back down and
asked
air traffic what that was they said we
didn't see anything so he said yes
whatever you need money-wise let's do it
and we did that we did
is so-called a-tip program we spent 22
million dollars of taxpayers money
and we learned a lot
okay that's that's a bit of a
cliffhanger senator you spent 22 million
and learned a lot but can you tell us
the top line of what you learned is
there life out there was that a ufo
on his wing we've learned that there are
lots of occurrences of an identified
flying
phenomenon we don't know what they are
but now the militaries
come around do they no longer tell the
pilots to ignore them
they don't want their pilots to report
them we have better photography
equipment
on airplanes and we're getting much
better pictures of where we got this one
called
tic tac off the coast of virginia uh so
we're learning a lot and what we have
learned is that
we haven't had a dozen of these
undefined flying
objects we haven't had 100 but thousands
of them
and that's all been identified i don't
know what they are
but i guarantee you that russia which is
run by
are ahead of kgb but they're looking
into it i know china's looking to do it
we know that france is looking into it
we should continue scientifically
try to figure out what this is all about
senator reid we'll have to leave it
there thank you so much for your time
please do stay safe thank you very much